ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita ha buttata ha visto che
siamo all'ultima puntata dell'anno ho
deciso di mettere insieme quelli che
secondo me sono stati momenti più
esilaranti di questo format da quando è
stato creato fino adesso ecco perché è
arrivato il momento di lanciare vita
buttata il best of uno mattina avevo
circa 13 anni erano le 7 e dovevo
portare fuori il cane prima di prima di
andare a scuola
allora mi sono vestito taglio sono sceso
nello stesso momento stava tornando
abbiamo da lavoro che hanno fatto il
turno di notte mi guarda e mi sono già
ma dove stai andando con il guinzaglio
in mano
guardo in mano e non può portare il cane
una volta che mi sono dimenticato
esattamente il cane
un giorno di tanti anni fa il mio
ragazzo venuto a casa mia e così di
punto in bianco mi ha lasciato ospite
andato via dopo un po mi sono
addormentata si sveglio cercato il
cellulare sul comodino per vedere se
sarà sotto un sogno è sensato e nel
prenderlo è scivolato e ha battuto sulla
spigole che si è spezzato e mille pezzi
allora per recuperare il cellulare o
stato un bicchiere d'acqua e vi chiederà
quater ha lasciato sul cellulare che
quindi arango lo sa bene tutto un giorno
più spiegato arrivati non ebbero questo
è terribile questi succedono poi vi
chiedo ancora sullo spigolo cioè come ha
fatto per prendere il cellulare vuol
dire che cellulare stava per terra ma ce
l'ha ripreso le ha fatto forse ce
l'aveva in mano e che ha fatto vibrare
tu sei stava dormendo col bicchiere
faccio io quello lo voglio più vedere
auguri e quanto riguarda cazzate
era una volta arrivato delibera da te ne
sentirebbe compagna cioè non si sta
cercando di sentire la scala vr a
camerano sentiero adesso dell'ambiente
io voglio dire una cosa
smettila infine la faccia della vita per
quanto riguarda io no vabbè mi spiace
sono mortificato non sono solo clienti
andiamo avanti
per quanto riguarda chi lo sa
gli scatti di rabbia compagni deve prima
e seconda elementare
[Musica]
non sono un paio di finali si possono
darci messo sette ore per te vento non è
più questo questo zoo ti racconto di
questo primo appuntamento ormai
risalente a diversi anni fa
in realtà è sbagliato definirlo primo
appuntamento nel senso che lui non si è
presentato quindi mi sono beccata una
buca clamorosa ma solo il giorno dopo ho
scoperto che non si è presentato perché
era stato arrestato
la sorpresa più di merda è stata quella
che ho fatto io al mio ex
ho deciso bene di fargli una sorpresa a
casa lo trovo a letto con la mia
migliore amica un trans con la parrucca
e insieme a loro c'era anche un cinese
vestito da quota inutile dirti che me li
sono immediatamente andata e non ho mai
più voluto vedere né lui la mia ormai ex
migliore amica era la mistery box e
magari semplice aperitivo è vero era un
semplice aperitivo grazie al recco un
caso appese a fatta lui a lei
io le avete scritto
valuto coperto del cara inventato un
incubo ma ha scoperto ogni cosmari
toccata al posto di casa perché non
vieni ragazzo fingeva di stare di
tradirla sgombro cito testualmente lo
studente proietta immagini inappropriate
sulla lavagna interattiva multimediale
sono che le immagini inappropriate
consistevano in indizio che sono mai
cenato con il vino in questione libica
perché ha fatto le cose seriamente
[Musica]
è un talento con un altro ma cosa
tantissimo tutti sarebbe da camera a gas
l'ubriaco posto nemmeno improvviso
sì esattamente
è in diretta live grazie ai stock a nato
forse la cosa più orribile che possa
capitare un essere umano da adesso non
possiamo fare tutti
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
basta volevo raccontarvi di quella volta
in cui un mio amico un monologo davanti
a numerosi spettatori in cui diceva che
i ragazzi con bocciate le cave modo
migliore sostenendo vai o bastato è
rimasto circa due ore fuori da casa
dopo di che è andato a letto ma
purtroppo non siamo solo io e guglielmo
qui a fare questo video e abbiamo un
disturbatore perché quando ride poi
fallite aiutato a posto e voluto godermi
invece sono a sentire cosa voce
[Musica]
[Risate]
diceva già ma cosa che fa ridere 80
niente basta basta
e questa era la malattia buddha di
natura una penna davanti con lui la voce
che cosa va trovato da piccoli è quello
il problema è tutto lì
[Risate]
ovviamente carta riassorbendo si può
fare niente
lei scrive che sta finendo
ciao puglia volevi una cosa senza senso
ti sto mandando la registrazione mentre
stop
allora siete voi che allora colpa vostra
allora sono ragione loro lui cerca di
turi cardi qualcosa così con cortile
interno
praticamente ogni notte si sentiva un
altro appartamento aprire la finestra
della sua camera urlare la tortura più
brutta che mi lascia il mio fratello ho
capito neanche una parola ok prova a
vedere se vai ti torna la tortura prima
di tutto la tortura dove chi mi si
chiamano come una mattina dell'estate
con storica ok acqua fisco ma alla fine
il lega pro timore o a una vongola come
animale domestico dolcissima mai un
animale in casa che una vongola o
comunque arrivi in un acquario e ogni
tanto di grandezza pari e poi ritorni
sotto bellissima ragazza tra l'altro si
il cav ha messo il tappo che bellissima
9 la mia vendetta più grande è stata
quando il mio miglior amico e ha tradito
ed è andato con la mia fidanzata quindi
tutti e due dei grandissimi e io ho
mandato a casa sua un pacco di
letteralmente mandato un pacco con della
cacca di elefante all'interno tramite il
sito che si chiama sciita express e alla
modica cifra di 15 euro mi sono
vendicato con della nota suite express
la scelta per santana grosso questo
pacco 15 euro 15 euro di mancate
nel senso che non sapevano possedere
fatto c'era proprio la foto che c'era la
foto delle tante che aveva fatto così
anche se lo ami pollici in una doppia il
mio compagno di stanza privata nella
stessa stanza
altri come nostri coinquilini ogni
mattina è entrato nella nostra stanza al
dolo la tapparella in mano sempre la
stessa non so la sveglia sveglia è già
mattina adattare la cia già su vieni in
cucina e questo ogni giorno per mario mi
vorrei ascoltarla la mia sveglia la
mattina la tapparella chi alza su vieni
in cucina ok venga sveglia la mattina la
tappa della piazza su denis in cui
viviamo che questo è il tempo che
maestro allora
[Musica]
e già mattina la campanella si alza su
vieni in cucina bellissima così è come
fa la scritta belli share triste sarebbe
la cover lana del rey
[Applauso]
già fatti
[Musica]
si no
bellissima comunque sveglia sveglia è la
nuova intervista dovremmo regalare quel
mix e rihanna eminem svegliato
[Musica]
no
il dg
[Musica]
lui adesso sta mandando un messaggio
vocale
ho fatto questa cosa preso il cellulare
ha fatto partire messaggio vocale ha
messo un walkie talkie vicino si è
allontanato di tre chilometri è fatto
no non lo dire mamma mia credo che stava
con la ricetrasmittente anche i talk
show o una scusa è stata da parte di una
mia amica dieci anni fa inventava la
scusa che lei non aveva posto in
macchinari a che i posti erano occupati
dai veloci che dire niente beh herat è
omologato amici
[Risate]
ma chi guida il regalo di compleanno
fatto la mia amica lucia si è un sex
toys con me il fatto che un avvitatore
[Applauso]
questi video e arte a qualsiasi momento
barbieri marzo in suono
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
chiaramente che si gira ragazzi sono
arrivate fini questo video prima di
salutarvi ci tenevo veramente a
ringraziarvi di cuore per l'anno che è
stato ringrazio gli ospiti che si sono
prestati a venire negli studios di casa
mia ringrazio tutti quanti commenti che
mi sono arrivati quelli che sono stati
messi quelli che non sono stati messi
ringrazio tutte le persone che hanno
contribuito con le loro idee a creare
nuovi temi per vita buttata io veramente
vi auguro delle meravigliose feste ma
soprattutto spero che per voi il 2019
possa essere un anno meraviglioso che vi
dia un sacco di soddisfazioni storia di
continuare a essere parte del vostro
nuovo anno io che dire vi mando un bacio
e niente c'erano il 2019
ciao